[Musique]
je vais commencer par cette histoire et
entre en parallèle avec ce qu'avait dit
la speaker promettait lorsque prométhée
décida de voler le feu des dieux pour le
donner aux hommes il n'avait pas fait en
sorte d'être fidèle à son nom prométhée
le prévoyant ceux prévoyant qu'ils
étaient un petit peu d'études n'a pas
tenu compte de ce que lui a infligé deux
pour avoir donné aux hommes le pouvoir
d' inventer et donc il a fallu dire
qu'une 9e le sauver
là encore il était obligé de porter le
pacte de fer attaché à une broche du
caucase pour le restant de sa vie
c'est une histoire triste
quelque peu triste certes mais qui
devrait nous pousser à méditer sur ce
que nous aurions pointe
régie limouzi magie de sa lésion ces
exemples comme leurs noms l'indiquent m
poney mais tout ce qui est exact clair
précis qui suit le principe de la
causalité directe entre les mains nous
appelons cette attitude le déterminer et
donc cette attitude là régner sur la
physique classique dans le but était de
connaître sur un phénomène naturel en
chaque instant et en chaque lieu est en
quelque sorte il était inconcevable pour
une personne saine d'esprit de ne pas
devoir de ne pas en voir tout le monde
relations sur un phénomène le manque
d'information était un handicap total
ils voulaient tous faire des trucs du
genre
sachant ça alors ça othon famille
le problème c'est que depuis ce 14 août
les phénomènes naturels qui était trop
complexe et trop insoluble pour la
visitation les problèmes dit finissais
mes limites et la musique classique
non car cette nouvelle discipline et à
part la relativité les gestes pour
résoudre les problèmes d'ordre
macroscopique naquit une discipline
fortement controversée la musique en
terre la physique quantique une
discipline qui décrit comme le concept
ray d'un physique tu as également une
discipline des concepts probabiliste et
qu'on sait proville isme pas sur un
principe qui était totalement hermétique
aux des trafics obilale le principe
d'incertitude d'un effet le principe a
atteint six en bulgarie zay pour le
comprendre si ghosn il dit qu' on ne
peut jamais avoir toute l'information
sur un phénomène naturel
quelque chose de pénible on ne peut
jamais avoir exactement taux de
l'information que l'on lisa
en un temps bon on attend ou les
physiciens aimé se dire moi je ne peux
pas ne pas touchent pas tout savoir
pourquoi dans ce domaine est venu un
physicien sur mon crâne d'un objet âge
il est venu neuf et six mois je
choisissais de l'époque de sa mort
prenez un petit peu de temps pour
pondérer cette question nous faisons
face à une discipline universelle qui a
totalement tourné son dos de concept sur
lequel était basé réfléchissons un petit
peu jette la toxine sns affirmé que le
pays subit non mais un jeu nul n'est ce
pas la preuve c'est que ça a marché mais
des phénomènes qui ont été totalement
justifiée car ça c'était si terrible et
de plus d'après a refusé à tenir des
glaces pas de limite de validité
le doré les hier kadhafi
mon père va je te sais que même dans les
deux histoires d'îles la mythologie
dirigisme ce que l'on a pu apprendre
c'est que les mélanger est une très
mauvaise d'ici là du tour mais en fait
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que avec le
partage du convention d'été tiède et que
je les vois lille et il peut être fatale
il peut vous garantir que je vois quand
vous traumatiser
d'airolo mais sommes-nous temps cette
vie pour rester peinard et confortables
et bien la réponse est oui nous avons le
droit de me confortable mais pas de
manière facile à rester les bras croisés
à ne rien faire en train de consommer de
l'oxygène gratuitement parce que si
c'est ça ce que vous voulez connaître
que des abris là encore moins que des
abris au moins ils consomment que disent
que du co2 l'anatomie je sais et donc le
message aux aliens a parfois créé des
tomates onirisme 22 des décisions chouïa
embarrassant le 13 dans les deux groupes
de jeunes a tourné ce régime logique
dans un puits sans fond je veux une
impasse mais c'est long il faut
travailler aux outils peut-être à notre
petit coeur c'est là qu'il faut pondérer
réfléchir et invente bien celle du mac
appelé nous est familier avec le concept
d'un manche j gorge de process de
l'additional la jda pour exiger qu'il
doit la créativité qui s'injectent le
processus bien l'invention avec la
créativité
l'ict avec un gros chien ben spies
l'inventivité pour être inventivité ils
se doivent inclure toutes les
composantes l'affluence c'est à dire la
capacité de conduire brainstorming
solide la flexibilité
après l'attention aux détails et
l'originalité
là je trouve que ma planète au mexique
c'est un point clé le pro que
l'incitation anglaise
spec auxerre n'est pas si innocente que
ça
elle amorce un mode de raisonnement
complètement il ose l appel à être
inventifs a dépassé ses propres
capacités intellectuelles être à être
reconnaissants du temps de la raison qui
nous a été volé je veux donner l'exemple
mais avant de vous donner un exemple
maintien dans le groupe vont appréhender
la station verte et k3 cabaret à la
blague n'a dès lors s my business et
c'est mon cas que le bon sens et la
divisant la plus juste entre les hommes
un demande cen-sad avec aurait trouvé
que pour s'emparer des rênes s il est
mon activité à un autre il dépend du
contexte socio culturel ainsi que de
l'intérêt ou l'instinct et lexie la
lucide et donc les habitants de grand
chose là bas ils s'adaptent selon les
capacités ou les contraintes des
couleurs écrit je vous donne un exemple
je dîne à un problème x à malines est
finalement ils ont tous les deux à
l'occasion elle connut jamais univers la
guerre et penser d'une désunion avant de
résoudre à notre avis sur l'euro la
livre et écologique et la méthode
éprouvée à kristen wiig sur un site
capable d'écrire avec le petit laps de
temps
leaké après avoir vu le problème est à
prendre l'avoir entamée même vous ne
vous ne vous en souvenez pas vous vous
souvenez de la révolution
qu'on fait avant et donc c'est ce qui
fait que je viens dehors
une manière de penser et de ce jeu qui
sort n'est ce pas il reste au même
niveau des colloques when and love et
rue de manière décente il était l'un des
trucs comme ça qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences néfastes sur l'ol se servir
eux-mêmes et chéquiers jeté par un
problème l'essentiel c'est de mesurer
avec l'accord a pour unique la
souffrance
bien sûr je ne vous demande pas de gros
aux écorchés la chef car c'est triste et
réjean parce que si c'est ce que vous
voulez faire et bien volé mérite
je vous demande seulement de mesurer
l'apport que vous venez aux autres car
c'est cet argovien qui va vous faire
dire mais ce que j'ai fait en vaut la
peine
donc pour conclure ce petit voyage
j'aimerais dire merci à une personne qui
m'a inspiré a élaboré son speech une
personne qui a amorcé en raisonnement et
qui l'a conduit jusque là il s'agit bien
sûr de prométhée parce que sans lui
déjà il n'y aurait pas eu ce thème elles
sont le concept avec lequel son histoire
elle est venue nous n'aurions pas pu
promouvoir la créativité l'inventivité
et la productivité
en espérant que ce petit trou et a
réussi à vos attentes
d'une manière ou d'une autre selon m
[Applaudissements]